all right this is another one i haven't
seen but uh
daytona hypernova this is from this
month bigot older brother around my
sister's
tiny kids he's a hermetic
alcoholic who beats me all right well i
have no idea what this is
back up here but
i know you're trapped in here
what's happening
[Music]
outside outside come on
you can do it come on let's go
that house is a [ __ ] mess
puppies
an alcoholic was isolated and doesn't go
outside okay well we're finding out
dude clean your house
so my bigot older brother around my
sister's tiny kids
he's a hermetic alcoholic who beats me
all right
so i guess he's just this person's just
showing the house
that's my dad sitting in the
hallway downstairs by himself i think
the
kids that they're babysitting or right
there in that room or the room next to
it
he was just sitting down there spitting
i don't know what he's spitting
he's not very sticks
is is this is this is this when we see
the rest of sticks house
it's really weird this is the rest of
stick's house guys
very welcome man
and my older brother
who's a alcoholic who beats me in this
house
i just went downstairs
and said hi to the kids that they're
babysitting
he took his dogs outside to uh
you know to pee
and these people are 100 okay with him
i don't
i haven't seen him do anything bad
except call the dogs out
my sister is 100 okay with him being in
this house beating me
while she brings her kids here to
babysit you have
facial hair you're an adult
why are you letting another man beat you
up this isn't if this was a child
that was getting beat up but you're an
adult
right this is an adult right we're
looking at an adult man
yeah [ __ ] move out you're an adult
leave
her and her husband are out having a
good time
relying on an alcoholic to assist
in the raising of and babysitting of
those children
but again you're an adult in that house
you could also help take care of the
okay
i don't believe look the house is a
[ __ ] wreck and it's a mess
but i don't believe
i don't believe a lot of what this guy
is saying
those children are one years old two of
them are a year old or so
and one of them is a two and a half
going on three years old i think
she has three kids with her husband and
they all
oh that he beats me in fact he does it
right in front of them
you're you're an adult
call number or call the police
[ __ ] leave i i don't
i is there videos of him beating you up
maybe that i could see
because i don't think that's what's
happening i don't think you just don't
like your bro
big brother or whatever they're all
irresponsible people and
i have to get out of here up to move out
and tired of living around this smell
then move out i don't know what happens
with the kids
because that's terrible oh you okay yeah
yeah you're not moving out because
you're broke
you're moving you're moving because
because you're altruistic and you're
taking care of the kids
um this guy has more videos hold on
there's sony 70 views here folks
we might be stumbling across [ __ ]
gold
well look it looks like they cleaned up
in this video it looks like there were
kids playing they looked they cleaned up
all the kids toys
so far every video is about the dogs
that i'm seeing all i know is that man
beats me in this house
my brother's out there talking to
somebody about something
dude this only has 70 views thank you
whoever sent this to me i'll give you
credit when i look it up again
this is fresh this is fresh
but all i know is that man beats me in
this house
when i'm in drag this man who's standing
out there on the porch
it is sticks
also thank you to the person who sent me
the other video
but thank god i decided to look in this
thing
how did you not send me this video
daytona hypernova 35 subs
this is let me get a bucket it's time to
milk
subscribe
preaching some fake ass gospel about
himself
well now we know why he gets beat
i'll tell you what so far i haven't met
this quote-unquote alcoholic brother but
i think he's a
i would rather have him around the kids
than you
oh boy oh boy we okay we're backing up
we're backing up for the big reveal
again sorry
we'll start let's do this
this is amazing this is amazing
well i grew up here yeah
what but all i know is that man beats me
in this house
when i'm in drag this man who's standing
out there on the porch
preaching some fake ass gospel about
himself
some fake ass gospel when he's a male
chauvinist
drunk ass hermit in this house without a
job without a life
beating male hurt
me when i'm half his size less than half
his size
in front of family in front of his
parents in front of his older
or his younger sister who's older than
me who knows this
and doesn't care i was right in front of
her the last time
one of the last times not even the last
time there's one other last time she
attacked me
it was on my birthday weekend of my
birthday
this man is nuts and he's out there
talking some preachy ass gospel [ __ ]
about saving what he really means is
black
like kick out the entire portion of the
neighborhood which is like seventy
percent of the population whoa
hey hey hey hey can we hear your
brother's views here real quick
okay now i gotta he beat you cool cool
can we talk to your cool brother though
can we can we talk to your cool brother
with the cool ideas
huh i'd love to hear your let's a
let's hear his brother out might have
some good ideas shut up
we want to hear your brother [ __ ]
slap him on his [ __ ] face
the neighborhood what he really means is
black like kick wait let me let me let
me i want to hear what his brother said
because i missed it
nuts and he's out there talking some
preachy ass gospel [ __ ]
about saving the neighborhood
what he really means is black like kick
out the entire portion of the
neighborhood which is like 70
of the population here why don't they
just kick you out
dude this is oh my god i'm so happy i
found this
thank you again whoever sent this to me
you are the real hero
at least because he doesn't like
people he doesn't like poor people he
doesn't like people he doesn't like uh
hey hey hey hey quit digging bud you
already struck oil
i'm up i'm on board
tell me what else this your awesome cool
based brothers
about
oh [ __ ] uh what do you feel like women
he hasn't been with a woman in the six
years that he's lived in this house
he does not do anything he never leaves
the house he shouts at
football games and basketball games and
goes on just tirades
and rants this guy sounds like me
i'm a guy like me i shot at football
games
and i go on france
usually during football games
it's a weird coincidence
at the football games and the basketball
games and everything where most of the
athletes are
he shouts racist things at all that man
is
chris martin goes do you also like pro
wrestling in video games because if so
i'm in man
can i hang out with your brother and put
some pants on
so out of control and i'm just getting
video footage of all of this
and he's talking to some lady on the
porch right now about
some nonsense that he wants to do for
the neighborhood the man beats
the [ __ ] out of me in this house
repeatedly
and every time he does so it's because
he's a drunk fool
who never stops drinking liquor he
doesn't even
he doesn't even drink a chaser and the
man doesn't even
but but again you're
who's dressing like a
sorry there's only one way to get out my
aggression
i walk bob dylan up on stage who the
[ __ ] are you
i knew the grateful dead from 1966.
who the [ __ ] are you i've been
doing anything but constantly drink and
preach and go
off and does nothing with his life and i
am the one who gets beat down this house
oh my god
as they would say in spanish
translation poor baby [ __ ] move out
yeah go home
forever standing up to him for anything
when he is
crazy unstable violent
he's crazy and unstable he's the crazy
and unstable one
i just figured out guys this is one of
them fight club things
he's both people here he has a based
alter ego that hates his
her ego he doesn't have a brother that
house is empty he lives by himself
his name was robert paulson
my sister lives right across the street
in this house then
go live with your sister
she lives right across the street and
why are you taxing her
and i like how they're saying 70 percent
of those neighborhoods
i'm looking at that house no it's not
you're lying no it's not that house
with her husband and three children and
they both know exactly what happens to
me
and they don't care nip i don't care
i don't care what happens to you nobody
cares
you're an adult male that dresses like a
and wants to be the perpetual victim
guys i mean
i'm so glad we got this early this is
only 36 subs
well i mean let me do this
this is absolutely not
here's the link lay your claim if you
want in the comments section we need to
plant our flag
plant your flag and that's the problem
they don't
care and that is so sad because it ruins
things for them
as well it's awful
this guy is is is there's more videos
and work
we're going deep here we go let's see
what else we got
another video
he's just trying to beat the that he was
trying to help eisenberg says
so his brother's listening to the
basketball game is what it sounds like
right
i agree if somebody wants to undertake
the task of of ripping his videos please
do
brother's town okay i just want to get
to here we go
when he's talking here we go i'm getting
a video of this right now because my
older brother is downstairs
slamming his fists repeatedly and
grunting and shouting
yeah he's a man watching a sports game
we all do i do that
we all do that at the television
because there's a game on tv and he
can't keep himself quiet he's burping
down there and he's
beating his fists he's slamming the
table
he's drinking excessively
and i can't even be around him without
him beating me
because he doesn't oh my god another
bathroom mirror video here we go
like people who doesn't like men in
dresses
yeah he sounds great
he doesn't like any challenge to the
binary of masculinity
and that means that anything about me
he beats down physically right in front
of mom and dad and my sister addie
and she brings her children right in
this house where he beats me
and she keeps doing it and he keeps
beating me
and i keep getting it on video guys
people are not mentally ill why do you
think that
what evidence do you have okay
a friend of mine starts like adam
adam [ __ ] ruins everything a friend
of mine is
in his truck okay we know but yeah
you're mentally ill all of you are
mentally ill
i'm not going to stop getting it on
video as long as all this is happening
to me
but you're not getting it on video
you're videoing yourself by yourself
whispering you haven't shown me one
video of him beating you
you haven't gotten one video of him
beating you
yeah you said you keep catching it on
camera where is where is i would love to
see the video of him beating you
or one bruce thank you can we see the
bruises that he leaves on you
you're lying because you're mentally ill
individual stixx i'm sorry
i mean daytona hypernova daytona
hypernova
so that's all i know to do because i
confront him i get beat down i confront
them about it and they
go crazy at me about it instead of
confronting him
and telling him he needs to get out
because he is a hermitic alcoholic who
never leaves
the house and beats people and is a
danger to small children
it is that simple and it's been that
simple since they got married it's
sad because they just keep ignoring no
a man who thinks he's a who videos
himself
whispering in the bathroom every night
is sad
so far i haven't seen any proof of your
brother being
abusive other than him watching sports
games like a person
so
easter sunday bigot easter sunday bigot
what a piece of [ __ ] talking outside in
his backyard at first i thought they
were hoarders but all that just look at
kids toys the backyard's actually pretty
well maintained right
oh it's a cute kid
what a piece of [ __ ] playing with his
children outside
this man needs to be stopped somebody
stop him
there's my dad sitting down that was my
older brother
now now he's just
this guy's a lunatic said trump
supporters
trump we figured out his problem we
figured out his problem
we've pieced it together we are
detectives it's not that he beats you
because i'm waiting to see the video
where he beats you i'm waiting to see
the bruises
it's because he likes trump
that's what it is there it is folks
we figured it out we figured it out
who beats me and hates people
and gays and women and blacks and
foreigners of any kind yeah he's out
there you know hanging out with his
child and being a good father
while you're wearing a dress in your
bathroom in his words
i think that's how i put it anyway
he's out there and those kids are out
there with them
all of us mom and dad's grandkids
yes their entire family is out back on
easter
while you're hiding in the bathroom like
a
that's what's happening here
the whole family is together having
family time
and i'm sure all your brother wants is
on easter
for his brother to come downstairs
wearing jeans and a t-shirt
and being normal have you tried
even put forth effort to be part of that
family because it seems like this
terrible person that you hate so much
the rest of the family is perfectly fine
being around him
and for as much as you [ __ ] and you can
[ __ ] complain
about what an [ __ ] he is because he's
the trump supporter
you're living in their house and they're
paying for you you are
garbage dude baby sat by them regularly
they're out there with
my sister her husband
all them it's a big easter party
wherever right we're all the families
together
you're the [ __ ] problem in this dude
daytona hypernova you're the issue
stupid not them you are
you [ __ ] nerd everybody's ignoring
the beatings that are happening in this
house
on a regular basis i keep getting beat
by that man who is over twice my size as
an alcoholic who never leaves the house
he's lived here years and years now
continuously beat me i have psoriasis
all over my arms okay so he's not again
we're not seeing bruises
we're seeing psoriasis again
all over my arms all over my legs i
can't even
show right now i don't have to but
anyway i mean it's all over
my body all of my psoriasis
this is actually pretty mild right now
because i'm on treatment
what does psoriasis have to do with him
allegedly beating you
please explain to me
but i'm at the mercy of doctors about it
because i can't afford the treatment ah
now we're figuring it out which means
you also can't afford to leave
because the person you're also a leech
who does nothing and you never leave the
upstairs
at least your brother ventures
downstairs and out back
medic i'm the only living member of the
family who actually has it it's a pretty
rare anomaly to have it
and it's stress correlated it bleeds all
over my body it's not bleeding right now
because i shouldn't take i took a shower
last night you should probably take a
shower every night sir
and no ordinarily it bleeds
especially in the winter right now it's
spring so this guy's psoriasis
is trump's fault or your brother's fault
but it bleeds constantly from climate
and stress anytime i'm stressed out it
bleeds
involuntarily it just starts bleeding
all over the skin and
every time i get beat down my body
bleeds
these people know exactly what happens
to my body they don't care where are the
bruises
i see your psoriasis show me the bruises
of you getting beat up
show me this guy's a liar
or how about have your phone recording
while he's beating you up and live
stream it
they are narcissistic people yeah
they're narcissistic not the guy that
needs to dress up like a
so everybody pays attention to him and
needs to be a victim online
you're right they're the narcissist not
you
daytona hypernova
narcissists and i despised
that anyone would allow that to happen
to anyone i don't want a person
oh you're right though they're the
narcissist
i mean i'm transgender i've been out of
the closet since 2011.
it's 2019 right now oh don't worry we're
gonna watch all the videos don't worry
about